oh [ __ ] it's that time you dirty
[ __ ]
what happened to me so beautiful day to
be alive say a prayer for a lay there on
fire
but [ __ ] we're gonna start all fire this
[ __ ] today you don't say it's a
bong hit exclusive today [ __ ] I'm
lucky you're here you're lucky you're
here you've made it you follow me
it's went down in an earthquake that's
me whacking off under the table Filipe
that's right [ __ ] you think you d little
we re coming at you today we got heat
coming at you today [ __ ]
we got a full bag of Purple's we're
gonna go deep today that's about to be
empty that's right
we got the refill at the casting agent
smoker before he grabbed Terry dicks
Terry Crews dig we got everything here
today you don't saying I got the weed
that made Louie take his dick out I got
the weed that made Boris I got every
type of weed yesterday and we're using
the big meal a full effect so if you
ain't ready to party you might as well
go back home [ __ ] go on family
look at cat videos this [ __ ] the mule is
hitting heavy duty today
so if you're not in the mood to get down
this ain't your type of [ __ ] party
I'm saying uncle Joey and the [ __ ]
MOT so please stop in full effect
that means Christ's killing Italian yo
saying look at this place we're gonna
blow off the [ __ ] lights today so I
don't know what you got thinking I don't
know what you got going on you might as
well go home right now if you got work
and let your boss know it's over
who the [ __ ] you think your dinner is
yong-chol Joey [ __ ] full effect
Wednesday the six of December 21 years
ago I got arrested today in Seattle for
[ __ ] assault and [ __ ] but [ __ ] it
when new people with new people today
that's what all that's what it all boils
down to you follow me if you hear you're
queer you made it I'm with you you're
with me and they're with us
it's the Church of what's happening now
three [ __ ] periscope [ __ ]
extravaganza listen I don't give a [ __ ]
if you got to eat an opiate it's your
lucky day
we got the stars of death in full effect
whoa open it up big tonight we're going
big numbers look at that big numbers
lead to other shots but let the
intestines do the work you follow me
it's a jujitsu let the technique do the
work you want to chew and grind like
that look
two at a time Lee no big [ __ ] deal
people do it all day long it's that type
of day [ __ ] you follow me that's
right you even got a wing you got a wing
a leg and a [ __ ] breast it's two
o'clock and we're going deep who the
[ __ ] you think you're dealing with
people huh you think when they show up
people an umbrella no we showing up with
[ __ ] hands with Vaseline on the
fingers [ __ ] no glove we're going in
deep pray for the [ __ ] universe you
follow me harder let's get on down in
the end you'll crack up fly down south
hide your head in the sand [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
we don't hide the head in the sand for
no one that's it this church what's
happening now some of that shit's a
beautiful day to be alive you know why
cuz you're alive [ __ ] you're
alive here you are
two o'clock Pacific five o'clock [ __ ]
East Coast time and you're swingin dick
and giving our [ __ ] crucifixes you
follow me it's
/ today please looking at me like what
did I get myself into
we've been [ __ ] around in the last
couple weeks we have been going deeply I
got shipments coming in from [ __ ] all
over
I got a shipment coming in from Thailand
are these mushrooms it makes you want to
finger bang a four-year-old
but anyway who gives a [ __ ] about that
type of information that's what the big
to-do told me we're just gonna keep
eating stars here - the clock breaks
leave like three or four behind you know
I'm saying I'm up to about eight I'm up
to about eight already we're gonna eat
this whole [ __ ] bag somebody's going
to the hospital today
down by one one call TMZ [ __ ] like
that just keep swallowing you don't give
a [ __ ] it's like when you're sucking
that horn ladies you just keep
swallowing don't worry about nothing
you're going out to dinner afterwards
it's [ __ ] tremendous the sponsors
this show sponsor today bye hello Lucy
calm you want to get your dick sucked
you might as well have your [ __ ]
clean you follow me number two if you're
a fat [ __ ] and you're joining jujitsu go
to Fuji Sports calm and tell them uncle
Joey said [ __ ] pressing Church and get
50% off and get yourself the best gear
on the market yet the sefirot e the SEPA
rito whatever the [ __ ] it is you won't
be sorry
I'm a fat [ __ ] people who gives a [ __ ]
about jujitsu it's Wednesday we are
alive [ __ ]
prove it to me do your twenty two
push-ups rate your goals tell your boss
to suck your dick
or you're just showing up like Harvey
will escape on because you don't give a
[ __ ] jack it's that type of day listen
this is all you need in your life right
here the anthem
the anthem of life if you're not [ __ ]
listening to dogs every day the morning
you're slipping if you're not listening
to dogs watching [ __ ] Lennox get it
live from Oakland if you're not watching
the Allman Brothers 71 from the film or
watch what heart is all about this song
right here I was down I was [ __ ]
nowhere I was lost I was a 15 year old
kid my mother died listen to this [ __ ]
right here
[Music]
note that guitar is brother listen joy
that's pain
[Music]
it's time for a bucket that's right
why absorb all this pain hey listen
David tremendous this song lives in my
heart right here are you kidding me get
the heroin ready it's too much it's too
much
listen Jim one was on fire baby what's
this here for any old G from perennial
top-notch it's over
you winter yeah
you ready and when you lose control
maybe it is right there
I hit it the answer you reap the harvest
you have so that's it [ __ ]
I got no problems you know why I used to
have problems but I brought up upon
myself is it they're giving you [ __ ]
answers as the fear grows they're giving
you the answers
[Music]
slight [ __ ] black helium his family
it's too much it's too much this is you
don't need no [ __ ] psychiatry not you
put this on every day you do ten bonnets
and put the earphones on let your mind
take you where you need to go so have a
[Music]
Betty Lee wait do you see the newly
[Music]
oh oh that's what you hear when you can
leave the Voodoo Lounge no no no no look
at Lee without the beard
little bit little stuff we got lugnut
let's do this [ __ ] okay this is the barn
of death right here don't worry about
money and you finish you have do the
breathing exercise
[Music]
tip-top ago
ready for the bonnet no no no listen
you're a liberal you're always ready
[ __ ] soldier the church right the
[ __ ] got cunningham wakes up early
morning [ __ ] Dickie sigh at VP of
Operations this [ __ ] meal too late
ladies and gentlemen that's all you need
brother
there you go that's the meal of death no
oh what the [ __ ] you think you're [ __ ]
with people I'm taking it to the next
level here you want to keep [ __ ]
around with your little vapor plans and
you [ __ ] you friends or you want to run
with your uncle Joey 2008 teens a whole
new [ __ ] year at the church here with
doing things different things what type
of things you don't know I can't let
this smoke go to waste
understand me we got time to [ __ ] around
no more the only [ __ ] is right this is
the weed that sank the Titanic you
understand me
they keep telling you people oh it
bumped into a glacier [ __ ] you this is
what the [ __ ] captain smoked when
that [ __ ] boat capsized and [ __ ] so
what else is goin on nothin the tour
with wheeler Walker I tell you what
that's my brother that [ __ ]
[ __ ] talented his [ __ ] if you came
out they handled me model from the heart
you guys rocked it his audiences
tomorrow Sacramento be busy [ __ ]
Friday two shows sadly two shows but
guess what they sold out did you [ __ ]
up
and besides that alone what the [ __ ] the
table listen with doing more pundits in
we're just getting the police prodigy
some more stars here girl Sam the one
deep of murky waters today that bong
doesn't [ __ ] around you think I have
this bond because it's a collector's
item suck my dick I don't want to like
this
[Music]
I'm trying to kick up the kick it up a
little bit we're moving into the
intermediate level now pockets your
barley and that's it and that's that the
rest is up to you
it's December 6 [ __ ] you got
what 18 shoplifting days left and you
want to sit there and stare like I did
something wrong you better get out there
and on top of that you got to get your
goals ready for Jill January first it's
a whole new year I got a set of them I'm
doing I'm changing up the [ __ ] game
my own game nothing else my own games
got a change dog I've been slipping
lately I'm not gonna lie to you people
it's not like I'm out there shooting
heroin no I'm just uh I'm gonna plateau
in my life on 54 and I gotta make
[ __ ] change as you follow me we ain't
going nowhere please stand especially
after the tape that came out of leave
out of space there's nobody or higher
once they see that [ __ ] tape it's all
over but the shouting you're following
me but you know what I love you
[ __ ] all year we've been
banging out we'll talk about some
fucked-up [ __ ] on the church today but
I've noticed this year about this year
and how to deal with the [ __ ] what's
coming up all right [ __ ] and
that's it and that's that
we're just here with Pink Floyd Lyrae
from the box not what we're training
this is how you that's ok that's ok
that's you have to keep on the training
it's like when you're gonna kettle bell
class and he goes into the 45 pound you
do it a couple of days now your adjusted
to it
that everybody is acceptable and no one
has a real friend
[ __ ] anyway we're here with queer the
rest is up to you you got the world by
the balls don't take off uncle Joey
things have been [ __ ] you things have
been like me you've been slippin
that's all this don't put it on life
don't pull on society put on yourself
you know when you slip and cut this [ __ ]
get that [ __ ] notebook out let's
write out these goals let's attack 2018
like real [ __ ] soldiers of the church
aka get lentils [ __ ] it we're gonna deep
comes and for you Spanish [ __ ]
are a dead get into my mother my finger
he may attend to my language cool a wire
a little added bonus
lengua and the culo means it's humbling
you [ __ ] you're not gonna learn that
on Sesame Street you follow me anyway
you know I love you [ __ ]
youtube.com slash Church slash Joey Diaz
that's the way to be we're gonna live in
ten [ __ ] minutes we're just gonna
listen that will the hayloft the rest of
this [ __ ] how there we go
maybe do a little bonding together what
do you think where do you get this type
entertainment Netflix [ __ ] no we just
show up when we show up concept is TV we
interrupt original programming the only
thing that beats this is love to Rhea
tackle this you follow me
st I'm pre-empting your [ __ ] day
that's how I do it cuz this is what you
need you need a break while the [ __ ] is
trying to hold you down [ __ ]
trying to tell you what to do [ __ ] them
all it's your world you only got one
shot at this Jay I want you to get up
right now March outside that office and
smoke pot right in front of [ __ ]
building and tell them all the suckin
dick
the price of necklace is going up and
we're smoking more weed over here get
rid of Netflix save the money smoke more
weed and let me hit listen to this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
always brought up in a house full of
pain who was
[Music]
who is trained not to spit in the sack
who was told what to do by the man
[Music]
this is it this drops it [ __ ]
you want the anthem or you want to keep
[ __ ] around jumping up and down with
these half of [ __ ]
better the back
[Music]
who was breaking away
breaking away who was only a stray juror
and all are you [ __ ] who's the
stranger at home how much acid be able
to do to think about that [ __ ] line I
remember I will fresca
when messing around with THC products
here we go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we go who was dragged down
are you [ __ ] nuts or what
who does this type of [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz let's get this [ __ ] party
started [ __ ] and remember that
didn't get my mantle opinio he meant
that de la lengua hang a cool language
culo means turn up your ass that's an
added bonus for the weekend stay black
[ __ ]